I have great news for you get 50% off
new annual daily wire plus memberships
we've made huge investments in
entertainment like my hit documentary
what is woman we launched more
investigative journalism and on the
ground reporting plus we're building an
entire alternative economy with Jeremy's
razors chocolates and more than that and
most recently we made good on our
biggest promise to date by launching the
dailywire new kids streaming app Bend
key all of this is only possible because
of our members just imagine how much
more we'll accomplish when you all join
the fight purchase your membership and a
few more for your friends and
[Music]
family